-Performing "Yoga"
and "Organise"
from his debut album
"Mr. Money with the Vibe,"
give it up for Asake
featuring The Composers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yoga, yoga ♪
-♪ I dey on my way ♪
♪ I dey maya ♪
-♪ Make nobody kill
my yoga, yoga ♪
-♪ Yoga, yoga ♪
♪ I dey on my way ♪
♪ I dey maya ♪
♪ Make nobody kill
my yoga, yoga ♪
♪ Enemies, I get them too much ♪
♪ It is better to get them
surplus ♪
♪ Who go dey for you
no go take off ♪
[ Singing in native language ]
♪♪
♪ Yoga, yoga ♪
♪ I dey on my way ♪
♪ I dey maya ♪
-♪ Make nobody kill
my yoga, yoga ♪
-♪ Yoga, yoga ♪
♪ I dey on my way ♪
♪ I dey maya ♪
-♪ Make nobody kill
my yoga, yoga ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Singing in native language ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Singing in native language ]
♪♪
-♪ Organize ♪
♪ Every other day I organize ♪
♪♪
♪ Some of us are wise ♪
♪ Every other person over wise ♪
♪♪
[ Singing in native language ]
♪ Based on one or two polopolo ♪
♪♪
♪ I no go let anyone
control me ♪
-♪ Anything wey I wan' do,
I go do ♪
-[ Singing in native language ]
♪♪
♪ I no go let anyone
control me ♪
-♪ Anything wey I wan' do,
I go do ♪
-♪ Organize ♪
♪ Every other day I organize ♪
♪ Organize, organize ♪
♪ Some of us are wise ♪
♪ Every other person over wise ♪
♪♪
[ Singing in native language ]
[ Cheers and applause ]